How long have you been here? I don't know, it's hard to say. Time moves differently here in the TVA.
What does that mean? You'll catch up.
Time works differently in the Quantum Realm. I'm sorry, that must have been a very long 5 years.
Yeah, but that's just it. It wasn't.
For me it was 5 hours.
See, the rules of the Quantum Realm aren't like they are up here. Everything is unpredictable.
Welcome back everyone this is good to be my
brand-new Loki video all about the time variance
authority the time keepers and their connection
to the quantum realm in the MCU.
A lot of you have been asking if the TVA is
secretly inside the quantum realm.
This whole time.
Because the way the time works is a whole
bunch of Easter eggs and connections tying
them both together.
So we'll break it all down.
If you're brand-new to the channel I'm doing
videos for all the episodes, be sure to subscribe
to get them are also doing a giveaway for
Disney plus memberships all you have to do
to enter is be subscriber and just post all
your theories in the comments below careful
for spoilers for everything that happened
on Loki so far if you haven't seen the episodes.
But there are a lot of Easter eggs, references,
and characters connecting the Loki series
to the quantum realm and Ant-Man three quantumania.
Which will revolve around the quantum realm.
Even more as a plot device during Ant-Man
the wasp in avengers endgame marvel sort of
canonize the quantum realm quantum energy
as the key to time travel in the MCU the during
Loki episode one when he's getting this grand
tour the TVA sees this wide shot of the city,
it seemingly defies a lot of the laws of physics
as he knows it scientific principles not too
dissimilar from the tiny sized Quantum city
that we get a peek at during Ant-Man the wasp
and the quantum realm.
When Janet van dyne and hank him are flying
away Mobius tells him the time moves differently
here in the TVA, he's referring to the actual
building, the space where the Citadel exists
in later he shows Loki some of their technology
use to manipulate time travel in specific ways
Like the tempads they use to open portals
anywhere in space and time.
Think of them as being like the iPhone version
of Iron Man's time travel pad in avengers endgame
Just a much more advanced miniaturized version
of that they also have the smaller personal
devices they use for controlling time for
specific individuals when they're processing
time criminals.
Like we see during episode one they by the
end of those collars.
They mostly use that for comedy with Hunter
B 15 later.
But as an example of how advanced their control
of time manipulation has gotten in the distant
future during avengers endgame.
Ant-Man tells the avengers about how time
moves differently inside the quantum realm.
The five years between avengers infinity war
and Avengers endgame was only five hours for
him Mobeus all the TVA agents, the hunters
Ramona Renslayer, the judges.
The librarian even Casey, everyone at the
TVA seemingly lives for hundreds if not thousands
of years based on Sylvie's explainer too in
the last episode.
During Loki episode 3.
She said that she had to go back 100 years
in Hunter C 20's mind to find a memory of
her life on earth.
And she seems like one of the younger hunters
it in that memory from 100 years ago.
It looked like present day earth.
So that confirms a couple things that only
the way time moves differently for everyone,
effectively slowing or even stopping the aging
process.
But also that the TVA has to wipe or block
people's memories on the regular to make them
forget that they're all variants from alternate
timelines of the time keepers erased.
That's the whole reason why Mobius doesn't
remember leaving the other rings on Renslayer's table.
When she yells at him because he's had his
mind wiped multiple times probably for several reasons
Probably because he'd started to get suspicious
about the secret of the time keepers.
But also just in general.
Everybody is a said probably has their mind
wiped on the regular just to make them forget
about their own relative age and the passage
of time.
It's like the old trick Casino's play on people
to get more money out of you.
They purposefully avoid having visible clocks
or reference to what time it is if you're
not aware how much time has gone by minutes
turn into several hours and potentially they
get to bleed you dry even more so to speak.
You look at miss minutes for example, she
has 16 positions on her clock face instead
of the normal 12.
And notice how there's no minutes or hours
hands rotating around or even a secondhand
in their even more connections to the quantum
realm.
When you look at the hunters and Loki use
TVA technology like the wands they use to
disintegrate people, or the tempads to open
portals.
All the energy that they give up seems like
the same color as the quantum energy from
Ant-Man the Wasp.
And when Iron Man manipulates quantum energy
to activate his time travel pad during avengers endgame
Like is that Marvel basically canonized in
those movies that the quantum energy quantum
realm is the only way to time travel in the
MCU the only see this different movie to movie
series the series is the way people manipulate
that energy to time travel.
But that's why Marvel's biggest Time travel
villain Kang the conqueror himself is the
main villain of Ant-Man three quantumania.
Because all about the quantum realm.
And because you need quantum energy the quantum
realm to time travel in the MCU.
So pretty easy prediction to make that Kang
will be using quantum energy and the quantum
realm is a big plot device to clinical conqueror
as the name implies, so let you know where
elder world farmer.
Like everything in keeping with tradition,
like all other marvel movies that have come
before the pie be a little bit different from
the comic book version of Kang just to make
him a little more sympathetic the give him
a tragic backstory.
So you identify with him a little bit more
but it's the same basic premise, he manipulates
time travel for his own personal gain.
If you're not a big comic book reader, he
is the long time love interest of Renslayer
in the comics.
Who we've been watching this whole time march
to the beat of the time keepers for what is
probably hundreds of years based on how old
the younger agents are will get a little bit
more Renslayer's backstory in the next couple
of episodes of Loki, but the way they they
explained her.
So far Gugu bottom Roz talked about her character
is that she started out as a variant.
Like everyone else, she eventually became
a hunter than over time worked her way up
the ladder getting promotions until she eventually
became a Judge.
So she's been at the TVA longer than Mobius
and most of the other characters in the comics,
there was a subplot were Kang was also searching
multiple alternate realities, alternate timelines
for one where Renslayer was still alive after
his own version of her died the quantum realm
is like a nexus of the multiverse.
So to speak, a gateway to the multiverse.
Alternate realities in addition to alternate
places in the timeline.
Like Janet van dyne worn Ant-Man don't get
sucked into a time vortex.
You could wind up anywhere in any kind of
alternate reality they been making several
references to nexus events Nexus on Wandavision.
So given all these really deep connections
between the quantum realm of the TVA is the
time keepers citadel really the quantum city
or part of the quantum city or even a separate
place inside the quantum realm because it
seems like you don't get time travel without
using the quantum realm in some way right
now just based on all the evidence and some
of the things the producers of the Ant-Man
marvel movies of said in the past and the
Loki producers one, I think the quantum city
is going to be a totally different place than
the time keepers citadel physically it does
look a little bit different.
But obviously the teaser for Ant-Man and the
wasp and some things the can a follow-up on
during Ant-Man 3.
And if you look at the time keepers citadel
here looks like the space beyond their protective
shielding is perpetually dark as if it's in
outer space.
Not inside this very colorful space of the
quantum realm is like an explosion of color
down here it also on top of that in the comics,
the quantum city and the time citadel are
meant to be completely different places like
it.
No point during any of the stories where the
TVA shows up in the marvel comics do they
ever reference the quantum realm the quantum
city in the comics, is the place where the
Micronauts originally lived now.
Marvel lost the license to them I believe.
Because I think that they belonged to Mattel
or Hasbro or something like that.
But there were other insectoid creatures that
live down the quantum city is not a bunch
of humans just walking around in at least
so far just based on all the evidence it see
with the TVA is entirely made up of almost
humans as far as we can tell.
The only aliens we've seen so far are the
ones they've arrested.
Like Loki, the Skrull here, young Sylvie in
the flashbacks technically Loki and Sylvie
aliens because there frost giants but also
on top of that in the comics, the full name
of this citadel here is the citadel at the
end of time in it's called that, because it
very literally exists at the moment before
the heat death of the universe.
Like the vanishing point of the timeline in
at least originally the Loki producers on
the TV show made it sound like the TVA was
supposed to exist in it's own pocket dimension
outside of the sacred timeline to the to be
protected from the changes to the timeline.
Like we see Sylvie messing with the sacred
timeline crating all those branch realities.
None of that would affect the people walking
around the TVA citadel here, so at least for
right now without more evidence, I'll say
the TVA is not inside the quantum realm.
But everything they do all their tech in the
way they do things the way they operate is
completely based on the quantum realm and
quantum energy and that is even get into the
larger mystery behind the time keepers miss
minutes.
Or Kang the conqueror.
I will do new videos about all those things
after the next few episodes when they start
revealing more clues and Easter eggs the pace
of the Loki episodes is moving to the plot pretty fast
So I think is all reveal some big things about
the time keepers during episode four the funny
connection between Kang the conqueror in iron
man's time travel machine the MCU the is it
in the comics Kang the conqueror started out
as a normal historian named Nathaniel Richards
in the distant future.
Like thousands of years in the future.
And he was a descendent of reed Richards father
also named Nathaniel Richards.
Because he had access to historical databases
he uncovered plans for reed Richards old Time
Machine he created back during the 20th century,
remade it and used it for his initial time
travel mission to go back and become the Rama
tut character.
Later he wound up becoming the Kang the conqueror
character.
But initially.
He started out using reed Richards time travel
machine the just rebuilt so when the way the
marvel movies change a lot of characters back
stories, it would be cool if they use iron
man's time travel machine as an Easter egg
for Kang the conqueror's back story.
But everyone let me know in the comments.
Do you think of the TVA is meant to be inside
the quantum realm my full Loki episode four
video is going to post Wednesday just like
normal, also new rick and Morty season five
episode two video posting tomorrow.
So everyone click here for my full Loki episode
4 trailer video and click here for my full
Loki episode 3 video.
Thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe guys tonight!